morning all new details have emerged
this morning about the
next stage of our fight against
coronavirus but it comes alongside
a fresh warning of just when it would be
sensible to start
lifting those lockdown restrictions
let's take a quick look at the morning's
main developments
uh starting with this sky news
understands that the government is
drawing up plans for a programme of
nationwide surge
testing meanwhile scientists tracking
the spread of covet variants
have warned against lifting lifting down
too soon
dr stephen patterson of liverpool
university told sky news
that case numbers should be down to the
low thousands each day before
restrictions are lifted
all those numbers will rise again and as
the vaccine rollout rumbles on
the head of the vaccine's task force has
told sky news
that all adults could have had both of
their jobs by september or even
august if we carry on at the current
rate
the supply we're going to get will take
us to the position where we can
vaccinate as many people as the uk wants
to vaccinate
that's an incredible achievement so the
vaccine task force knows that it can
secure supply within roughly what time
frame
every adult two jabs of the coronavirus
vaccine well i think
we're probably talking august sort of
time always september time
all done maybe maybe sooner if if we
need to
we really need that uh headroom of
getting cases down before we can uh
really uh take our foot off the brake uh
otherwise we'll just
i think you know end up with cases
rising again and
uh starting to get to a place where we
where we don't want to be
meanwhile one london but a hardest hit
by covid19
has raised concerns about test and trace
capacity as we ease lockdown
our political correspondent kate mccann
reports
hello my name's kerry i'm from the newm
council where i'm from the local contact
racing team
newham has suffered more covert cases
than any other london borough
now the council is turning things around
staff like kerry are leading the local
test and trace effort alongside the
national scheme
when you make that call and on the end
of the line is someone who's
either really really ill or has lost a
relative you know very quickly
um very recently you know you go into
your brain obviously is very sad for
them and obviously you go into
empathy straight away but then
immediately that makes you want to help
them more
do you think you could save lives
definitely i think we do save lives
already and i think we could save more
but as lockdown lifts test and trace
will come under increasing pressure to
keep infections low and that
means difficult choices coming on the
back of significant years of local
government
austerity and a whole range of tough
choices
already facing councils add on that the
hit
that the pandemic has meant for councils
in terms of the
the wide range of financial impact that
it's had
and then on top of that you add all of
these additional things which we
absolutely want to do with
we want to do everything we can to
protect our communities but it's really
clear that we you know
the more resources that local
authorities have the more we're able to
do in this space
along with the push to get more people
tested here they've started paying for
hotels so people from overcrowded homes
can isolate away
from family and they've applied to the
government for funding to expand the
tracing service
seven days a week newm has been harder
hit than most other london boroughs so
asymptomatic testing centers like this
one are absolutely essential to stop the
spread
but when you couple this work with
staffing vaccination centers
surge testing and now expanding test and
trace
it's not hard to understand why leaders
are calling for more help
ministers have announced more funding
but labour says it isn't enough
i think local authorities have really
become the fourth emergency service
through this pandemic they've you know
they've moved heaven and earth to
support communities and they've done a
fantastic job
but without the appropriate funding from
national government
they simply don't have the resources to
do the job they want to do
and that we need them to do so often in
this pandemic there's been tension over
whether local or national
is best now both councils and ministers
are on the same page on test and trace
they can see the value in what places
like newarm are doing
it's funding not ambition which will
limit how much of a difference they can
make
kate mccann sky news
and as you can see kate joins us in the
studio morning km
look is your report and indeed the
government have often made clear test
and trace
is at the heart of our response to
covid19 but with eyes on the horizon you
know
papers this morning and indeed we've
confirmed this ourselves that there is
there are plans of food for i don't know
a surge
in mass testing yeah that's exactly
right and i think this is the next stage
we're going to start to see more of this
from monday
that the prime minister is going to set
out how we move out of lockdown slowly
and a huge part as you say
will be test and trace they're going to
be absolutely central to this and some
of that will be councils and that's what
that report was talking about there
the other part will be sending these
rapid lateral flow tests to our homes
and to our workplaces and that's going
to enable people to know if they are
asymptomatic
now when boris johnson is asked about
one of the regrets that he's had over
this pandemic what he always goes back
to is i wish i'd known
the asymptomatic spread of the disease
was widespread in the early stages they
know it now and they're going to try and
counter it and this
testing will be a huge part of that
hundreds of thousands of us will get
these tests around our
as i say homes and workplaces if you
don't have symptoms you'll take one if
you have covid you'll know about it
you'll isolate and that will be key
to stopping clusters from spreading and
ending up in another lockdown
uh more from you after we've spoken to
the minister thanks very much indeed um
well let's take a closer look as we
always do it those
latest coronavirus figures for the uk 10
625 new covert cases have been confirmed
and eight further 799 people have died
within 28 days of testing positive now
that brings the
uk total to 118 100
118 195
15.6 million first doses of the vaccine
have been administered
just a reminder the foreign secretary
will be joining us on the program
in just a few minutes time so stick with
us for that but also coming up
on the show with the government
discussing whether to roll out potential
vaccine passports we'll be looking at
the risks and the benefits of such a
scheme at
half past a quarter to eight we'll be
speaking to the
children's commissioner for england and
longfield on her last day
in the role as she calls on the
government to put children's center
stage
the prime minister's promise to build
back better from coronavirus
and a quarter to 10 i'll be talking to
one of the survivors of the 1972 andy's
plane crash
about his remarkable story staying alive
for 72 days
in the harshest of conditions
let's take you through a few of the
other stories at making news this
morning uh one in six people in england
could be on an nhs waiting list by april
due to strains on the health service at
the think tank reform
said the patients waiting a year or more
at the number of patients i should say
waiting a year or more
has risen by more than 12 000
since the start of the coronavirus
pandemic nhs directors say the
service will face a mammoth task to
tackle backlogs
if the predictions are correct
a judge has ruled that a civil claim
brought by the family of harry dunn
against his alleged killer
should go ahead in the united states the
teenager died in 2019 following a
collision between his motorbike
and ann sukula's car in northamptonshire
she was charged with causing the
teenager's death by dangerous driving
but claimed immunity as the wife of an
american diplomat and returned to the
united states
the parents are overwhelmed this evening
and
obviously our thoughts are with harry
who died 18 months ago and
it's difficult to talk about a victory
or a celebration but this is a
massive step towards the parents getting
some semblance of justice
the nspcc says there's been a sharp rise
in the number of people reporting
children
being put at risk because of parental
alcohol or drug abuse during the
pandemic
data shows the number of reports has
increased by 66
since last march with more than 38 being
logged
every day
donald trump has launched a blistering
attack on the senate's leading
republican
and his previous close ally mitch
mcconnell the now senate minority leader
had accused mr trump of being
morally and practically responsible for
the capital rights
although he did vote to acquit him at
the impeachment trial
in a statement the former u.s president
donald trump said this
at mitch is a a dire unsullen and
unsmiling political hack
with a lack of wisdom skill and
personality
adding that if republican senators
stayed with him
mr trump believes they will not win
again
next the case of a missing princess and
her secret video diary
and the foreign office says it's
concerned about a dubai princess
who says she's being held hostage in her
own country
in secretly recorded videos princess
latifah claims
she's been detained having been
kidnapped drugged and
taken back to dubai in 2018 after
attempting to escape
her father dubai's billionaire ruler has
previously denied the allegations
saying she was tricked into leaving
dubai by criminals uh
just a warning that the following report
from sky sagna burgess does contain some
flash photography
i'm in a villa i'm i'm a hostage
and this villa has been converted into a
jail all the windows are wired shut
for three years the world has heard
nothing from princess latifah
the daughter of dubai's billionaire
ruler mohammed bin rashid al-maktoum
but sky news can now reveal princess
latifah's story
we sent her questions and she replied
using a smartphone smuggled to her
in what she says is a royal villa in
dubai i'm doing this
video from a bathroom because uh it's
the only room with the door i can lock
latifah's father is the prime minister
of the united arab emirates
regularly seen with heads of state
including the queen
he has horse racing and property assets
in the uk
but latifah one of her sisters and two
ex-wives
have all claimed the sheikh abused them
he denies this
three years ago the princess says she
tried to escape
with friend tina yahinan i believe that
latifah has wanted to be free
all her life and um i'm not satisfied
until latifa is allowed to travel to a
country of her choice
and um and and get the freedom that
she's always wanted
they made plans with latifah seen here
practicing in the palace pool
in february 2018 they drove from
downtown dubai
into oman from muscat they took a small
boat
then jet skis to a waiting yacht and set
sail for goa
but just miles from the coast of india
and what they believed was safety
armed indian commandos boarded i was
prepared for anything
you know i'm used to much worse and i'm
prepared for anything i
was prepared to even lose my life for
freedom latifah says she was
forcibly taken back to dubai i was tired
i was up against a lot of people with
weapons
beaten and tranquilized he took out the
needle and he injected me in my arm
her father says latifa was tricked into
escaping
by criminals who wanted money and
returning her to dubai
was a rescue mission and that she is
safe
and well but much of latifah's account
has been accepted by a british judge in
a high court case
involving the sheikh and his former wife
princess hayer bent al-hussein
the sheikh rejected the findings and
said the judgment
inevitably tells only one side of the
story
pictures were released nine months after
the escape showing the princess with
former un human rights chief
mary robinson who says she was duped
into taking part in the photos
friend david hague who was also charged
and detained in the uae
over fraud allegations says he is hoping
the videos will encourage the un
and others to act we want politicians
and
former politicians and world leaders and
you know celebrities and so-called
influencers all the people that go to
dubai
in the uae promote that country to wake
up and see what the reality is this is a
country that is
literally i mean people will be on those
beaches in dubai a few hundred meters
away from
where latifah is is essentially in
solitary confinement
a hostage sky news agreed to run these
videos when latifah wanted them to be
made public
but nine months ago my secret
communication with the princess stopped
we don't know why or where she is now i
don't know what can happen to me
and how long this will last the united
arab emirates has not responded to a
request for comment
sanja burgess sky news i'm doing this
i will join once again on the programme
by the foreign secretary dominic
mr up it's been a while since we last
spoke so i do hope you've been well um
i i wonder if we might start with this
the the case of
the missing princess latifa what is the
british government's position on this
well look you can only watch the footage
that you've just shown now and uh
see that there's very distressing
pictures
a very difficult case and i think it is
concerning
we always raise human rights issues with
all of our partners including the uae
there's no particular british locus in
this case but we aren't concerned by
this
and i noticed that then we've seen that
the
united nations high commissioner on
human rights will be following up
uh on what we've seen and we'll be
watching and monitoring that very
closely indeed
from what you're saying it certainly
feels like we would not be in a position
as yet at least uh to talk about
sanctions
to talk about perhaps inviting the
ambassador in for a chat
we always raise these issues with all of
our partners across the police including
in the middle east where we have to have
some of these difficult conversations
i've always raised human rights issues i
always do with foreign ministers with
the
ambassadors and i think the right thing
given what the united nations has said
is to follow very closely and
we're obviously always supportive of the
united nations high commissioner
on human rights and i think that's the
proper course right now to follow those
developments quite closely
of course we do have a relatively close
relationship with the united arab
emirates there's trade of course there
are security concerns
one understands that you know this issue
is not going to immediately change the
the nature of our relationship but one
has to say you know given the fact you
know we had a uk court
ruling back in 2019 that not just uh
uh princess uh that they're not just
that princess
not just the princess has been abducted
her sister as well sheikha latif
sheikha samsa was kidnapped on british
soil
i mean on the basis that at least one
of his children looks to have been
kidnapped here don't we have more of a
responsibility to get involved
well certainly in terms of the private
law claim that went through the uk
courts obviously
we not only respect but we would expect
compliance with
uh any and everything that that it's
decided at to the extent we can control
that of course
and any criminal matters rightly for the
police and they should investigate them
without fear or favor would you mr rabb
support
seeing some kind of proof of life uh of
princess latifah
from uae i think given what we've just
seen i think
people would just that a human never
want to see that she's uh alive and well
of course i think that's a natural
instinct and we would certainly welcome
that
i i wonder if we might move on to to to
the announcement that you're making
today and of course uh the uk and its
role on the security council
you know it it is there are
opportunities for us
to push a number of agendas tell us just
a little bit though about the
ceasefires in conflict zones i mean
certainly we need to get the world
vaccinated for the world to get back to
normal and that
clearly will have to involve areas in
which there's conflict how would that
work though
so the uk is stepping up to the plate
we've got the presidency of the un
security council and you're right
there's two things we're particularly
focused on
the first is trying to get um a covid
uh vaccine ceasefire because with the
new vaccines which is a big change since
last year when this resolution was
uh pushed by the french with our support
we've got an opportunity to get to some
of the most vulnerable
around the world and one of the things
i've seen as foreign
is the compound impact abroad in the
most vulnerable countries for the most
vulnerable people
of three things famine conflict and
kovic
and so if we can uh through the un
security council which is the
international
community's top body for uh passing
rules and
and making uh statements around
international law and what's required
if we can just see a window of
opportunity to reach
those really vulnerable people in those
terribly afflicted countries
i think we'll be doing a lot of good and
that's what global britain is all about
and that's what we're going to be trying
to secure on top of the
support for uh the equitable
distribution of vaccines which were
already leading the way
in terms of the uh kovacs amc mechanism
we've provided 500 million pounds
that will produce uh a billion doses
again for some of the most vulnerable
uh people around the world there's the
two things we want out of this debate
uh later on today which i'll be sharing
indeed and
of course we are ahead of much of the
rest of the world not just in
in getting the vaccination into people
but in terms of the the purchasing
of the vaccine with a considerable
degree of foresight
when it came it came to hedging our bets
such as it was in in terms of who we
ordered from we've clearly got
on order at very least more vaccine than
than we could ever use
at what point do we start to think
seriously about about redistributing
that i mean we heard from the vaccines
minister at the weekend potentially not
until
every adult in the uk has had a vaccine
so first of all we're already trying to
support those
most vulnerable countries the lower
middle income countries around the world
and the right way that the international
community can respond and which we're
leading on
is the cove kovacs amc mechanism because
you put money in
it secures the doses the kovacs amc
arrangement has uh supply chains with
the different vaccine suppliers that's
the first thing it's the most important
thing
it is going to be the clearing call that
i make in the u.n security council later
today
it's true as well if we've got excess
supply in due course when we know
not just the amount of vaccines we need
but the timing we would
then want to think again whether there's
an additional router support that we
might be able to provide
we're not there yet but we're already
stepping up to the plate in the way i
described
by putting money in and using our
convenient power to get other countries
to match it
and that's the way we'll support the
most vulnerable countries the most
vulnerable people around the world
and show that we need a global solution
to a global pandemic
it is slightly away from your brief but
i'm sure it's something that the
that you know about the letters that
will be being sent out to around about
just less than two million people
telling them that they they need to
shield it it all seems the product of
this that this algorithm that is driving
at least part of our pandemic response
can you just explain exactly how we have
why we have found ourselves in this
situation
what the metrics that this algorithm has
identified
are and and how soon we might think we
can be in contact with these two million
people
so obviously we want to make sure our
response to the pandemic is updated as
we learn
more about the virus and and also about
the vaccines
oxford and it's called the cucovid
program has through data that it has
modeled
found that there is a particular
additional vulnerability
in relation to certain compound factors
so it's things like
age sex uh body mass index all put
together
and it's 1.7 million who we think um uh
are at greater risk
about half of those will already have
had
uh the vaccine or wrong calls to the
vaccine under the current rollout
so there'll be another uh around again
half of that number who were contacting
to say first of all you're now a
priority for the vaccine we want to make
sure they get it as soon as possible
and secondly we're urging them to advise
them to safeguard
until the end of march with all of the
support on things like statutory sick
pay
um guaranteed delivery of supermarket
and medicines
that will come with that i think it's
the right thing the responsible thing to
do to make sure
when we learn about people who are more
vulnerable to the
virus that we do everything we can to
provide them extra support
that's the approach and we'll be
notifying them immediately as soon as
possible
yeah i i'm sure that they will be great
for when when they're
when they're contact but just in terms
of how we come out
of the of this phase of covert covid19
that there seems to be a very strong
indication that what of course you have
always maintained
testing testing and tracing is at the
heart of of getting us out of this but
it feels like we are about to embark
upon
a program of mass testing around the
country to try and keep on top of this
as the vaccine
continues to be rolled out can you speak
a little about that
we learned um previously in places like
liverpool and other areas in the north
the value particularly when you've got a
spike of testing done
at scale and at pace particularly with
the new lateral flow testing
but as we roll out the vaccine and as we
start to think and the pm will set out
the roadmap forward
on mondays on the 22nd of february and
he'll set out the details
and as we get the feedback the data from
the impact of the vaccine
the two or three things that are going
to be really important uh if we're to
ease out of lockdown uh safely and
responsibly
uh yes of course the vaccine um the
therapeutics which aren't much talked
about but the drugs that help
uh take some of the fertilities that the
fatalities out of
um those that contract the virus but
also this lateral flow testing being
able to do it at scale
at uh pace so that when you do have
upticks
of the virus we can come down on it like
a ton of bricks and make sure
and it's only one part of the strategic
jigsaw if you like but make sure we can
come down on it like a ton of bricks
um so i said there's a range of
measures but testing and rapid natural
flow testing
is a key part of that um and minister
again
slightly away from your brief but but
i'm sure it's something that you you
will have a view on
we keep keep hearing in terms of the
quarantine hotel scheme
we keep hearing that passengers from red
list countries are
on the plane once they arrive in the
airport all the way in fact
to the border checks are being allowed
to mingle with passengers from from
non-red less countries what are we going
to do to sort that out
well we've got a series of measures in
place already you have to have a covered
test to get on
um a flight in relation to those coming
from the redless countries obviously if
they're
they're brits we've got to get them
safely back home and what we've devised
is the most
uh safe and effective mechanism that we
can we know that the numbers of people
traveling have come right down and we
have the
hotels and the hotel capacity um to make
sure that they can
then quarantine at home for 10 days
sorry not at home
at a a government commissioned hotel
uh in safer conditions it's only one of
the lines of defense and obviously we
we're struggling with this balance as we
have right the way through
and we're striking the right balance
between uh
robust measures to safeguard the vaccine
from coming in but also looking after
british nationals who
who we need to uh to cater for and take
care of we think we've got the right
balance i think the system is working
uh reasonably well but but as i said
it's only one of the safeguards only one
of the lines of defense
to prevent either variations from the
vaccine or people uh unwittingly
carrying the vaccine coming back into
the uk
at this critical moment uh dominic rapp
great to have you on the show this
morning uh thanks being with us
uh let's get a little bit more there uh
what we heard from the foreign secretary
about a report
on uh princess latifa uh dominic ram
telling us
that he would in fact support some form
of proof of life
uh being demonstrated our diplomatic
editor dominic wagon
joins us on the program at morning
dominic i mean it is a tricky situation
for the foreign secretary for the
british government of course because of
the ties
between the united kingdom and the
united arab emirates but as we heard
from the foreign secretary look
when you see those videos it almost
compels a need
to see proof of life the proof of life
of the princess
yeah i think it's fair to say that this
is an awkward
case for the british government because
as you say the ties between the uk and
the uae
are very close uh have economic ties
trading ties
uh tourism ties military intelligence
ties
and also the fact that this is the
friendship between the queen and
sheikh mohammed darmaktum because of
their shared love of horse racing
despite that uh the uk has been
commenting on this case
and i think what the foreign secretary
uh said to you is probably the
the most we've heard for a long time
from the uk government about the
case of uh missing princess latifah
saying that
these were distressing pictures uh it
was a very difficult case he said
very concerning in terms of whether
sanctions are likely to be imposed or
considered by the british government or
whether
you ask where the ambassador might be
called in about this um he reverted to
what we often hear from the british
government about sensitive cases which
is that
they always raise human rights issues
with allies and
governments lawyers and campaigners are
going to be
putting legal pressure on the british
government to try and encourage it to
impose sanctions on individuals in the
uae
as they have against saudi officials for
instance so we have to see how that
plays out but uh
no sign that the foreign secretary is
prepared to go there in terms of
your questioning along those lines uh
neil i think the british position is
that there's no as he said
uh particular lucas in this case for the
uk although it has to be said that
princess latifah's sister
shamsa disappeared from the streets of
cambridge 20 years ago
a uk city of course and uh sheikh
mohammed
denies any involvement in her abduction
but a british judge
did rule a year or so ago that
he continues that the sheikh continues
to maintain a regime whereby both of
these two young women both princesses
are deprived of their liberty albeit
within family accommodation um
in dubai uh but i think the most
interesting thing was
was as as he was saying there your
question as to whether he would like to
see proof of life and dominic rabb
saying on a human level
people would like to see that she is
alive and well so despite these close
ties between the two countries
these claims and the publicity around
them are undoubtedly straining those
ties
and i think to talk to the foreign
secretary to draw him out on that
talking on a human level about
this desire he would like to see and
others would like to see to at least
prove that princess latifah is alive and
well
that will put greater pressure on the
relationship between the uk
and the united arab emirates dominic
many thanks indeed
uh as we were hearing just a few moments
ago from the foreign secretary he's
calling for ceasefires in conflict zones
so that people can be vaccinated against
coveted 19.
sky's africa correspondent john sparks
joining us from johannesburg this
morning good to see you john um i wonder
what you make of this
plan from the foreign secretary of
course all very closely linked uh to the
position that we're
currently holding on the un security
council
yeah good good morning neil yeah the
foreign secretary there saying that uh
the british government is stepping up to
the plate what i think he's doing
the government is doing is recognizing
that the brutal reality of this pandemic
that
no one is safe until everyone is safe
until everybody has had
a vaccine but i have to say a u.n
resolution calling for
ceasefires in trouble spots so they can
these ceasefires can aid in the
distribution
of vaccines is not really worth very
much because
is linked groups in central africa
nigeria mozambique
they're not going to pay much attention
to that that is that is another reality
i'm afraid
but his call for a concerted action on a
more
equal distribution of vaccines around
the world i think that is
important and that issue really does
need a lot more attention right now
we have just come back from mozambique
we did a trip there for 10 days and i
can tell you
that nobody in that country has had a
vaccine not even frontline health
workers
well in the uk you've got middle-aged
people now getting their first job
you've got more than
15 million people that have had a jab so
the disparity there is absolutely huge
and something has to be done about that
people in public health workers in
mozambique were telling us that
it could take five years or more to get
the entire population in that country
inoculated because of the financial
difficulties because of the
huge logistical difficulties their
reality is different and at the moment
countries like mozambique vaccines are
aspirational
john thanks very much still to come on
the show this
morning we'll be looking at if a
potential vaccine passport
scheme could actually work that's next
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
welcome back uh the government has said
it is looking at whether coronavirus
immunity passports may be needed
in the future for international travel
but the prime minister has stressed that
he currently has no plans to introduce a
scheme
for domestic activities uh pleased to
say we can speak now to professor sir
jonathan montgomery
who specializes in a health care law and
indeed has been
looking at the matter of vaccine
passports and professor great to have
you on the program this morning um
given where we are in terms of the
vaccination rollout given what we know
about vaccine efficacy and
and transmissibility vaccine passports a
good idea or not
well this certainly isn't the right time
to be implementing them
the logic of a vaccine passport would
work
if having a vaccine reduces the risk you
present to other people of passing on
the virus
and we don't know that at the moment we
know that the vaccine reduces the risk
of the person vaccinated getting ill
so it's good for them but it doesn't
make sense to think about passports
unless it also stops them passing on
the virus to other people so this is
certainly not the time to be
implementing it
but it is very reasonable to be thinking
about pros and cons
just on that point though is this
perhaps not an occasion on which we
would be best advised we could have
crossed our fingers and hope
that the vaccines have some effect on
transmissibility and on the basis of
that
perhaps there could be an i understand
the distinction that you're making
but if there remains the possibility
that transmission is affected
is it not possible for at least an early
the early stages of a vaccine passport
scheme
well i think the public health case is
almost the opposite of that because
if it were the case that we were lulled
into a full sense of security
thought it was safe to do things and
then it turned out that we spread the
virus
then that would be much worse than not
going down that track
people who are interested in this are
primarily interested because it may help
us
open up the economy um and that of
course is something which is
really important to get everybody back
to work and their lives in place
but the real gain in that is getting
widespread vaccination
and we don't need the passport system
for that we need to focus on getting
everybody vaccinated
um just in terms of the the the legal
aspect all of this i don't know if you
shared
to share my view but it somewhat feels
given what we have heard from ministers
about domestic
vaccine passports and their reluctance
to see them used for services in the uk
the private sector is undoubtedly
going to have some effect and it may
well be that the government is somewhat
sitting back to let
a legal test case go to the high court
and all the way to the supreme court
i think it would be silly to wait for it
to go all the way all through the court
process
but they may well be looking to see
which areas of the market
want to use these passports the most
obvious ones at the moment
seem to be international travel and the
opening up of leisure
venues on international travel the key
will be
a global agreement because it's
important that every country recognizes
the vaccinations
from others and we've seen the debates
from for example france
about their approach to the oxford
astrazeneca
vaccine so there may be a lot of people
who don't get
this recognition but the global level
the world health organization is looking
at this and that's
must be the right vehicle uh to explore
it
domestically we should be worried about
who's going to be denied access
as much as worried about the hopeful
past
for a possible because most of us will
not get vaccinated for a while
i'm absent the government legislating
against the private sector acting in
this fashion is that is there any legal
barrier
to employers insisting that their
employees or even perhaps new employees
coming into the company
have had a vaccine
so it isn't i think lawful for employers
to require current employees to have a
vaccine
it may be lawful for them to put into
their recruitment
processes the desire that people are
vaccinated
from an employer's point of view it is
reasonable to try and make sure that
people are safe to come to work and of
course the vaccine helps with that
i will be much safer coming to work if
i'd been vaccinated because i'm like
unlikely to get seriously ill but if the
argument is that their customers
are safer then we're back to where we
started that that's only going to be
true
if they're less likely to pass the virus
on and we just don't know that at
present
so we might find ourselves with a
discrimination problem that
employers are unjustifiably
discriminating against
certain groups of people the
unvaccinated and of course they
tend also to be more likely to be
particular age groups and the current
vaccine program and also some groups who
are a bit more hesitant about taking the
vaccine because they need to be
reassured that it's safe
and if we found ourselves systematically
excluding some of those groups
then employers might find that they are
engaged in unlawful discrimination
but that's untested as yet professor
montgomery great to have you on the show
this morning thanks for your expertise
thank you now texas has issued a state
of emergency
after four million people were left
without electricity
because of a snowstorm the freezing
weather swept across southern u.s
states with tens of millions more facing
severe weather warnings
many seeking refuge and warmth in
emergency shelters
this sky's adam parsons reports now from
texas
in grapevine they are relying on
emergency generators for electricity
like many towns in texas the extreme
weather has caused a wave
of power outages many people are cold
and helpless they come to this impromptu
emergency shelter
set up in a leisure center here we meet
charles
tired but relieved i don't think i could
have stayed in there all night so
i think i did the right thing by coming
up into this warming station here at
least
to let me let me live another day you
know if you would enjoy it if you stayed
at home
probably so yeah in another room cherie
and her daughter zoe
after a night sleeping here they've
managed to find a hotel to move to
it's been you know rough but they're
doing what they can and they've been
phenomenal
but not everyone is so lucky hotel rooms
are rare and expensive in texas now
we're with belinda as she tries to find
somewhere warm for the night
do you have any rooms available tomorrow
night
oh no there's nothing available okay all
right thank you
we're not used to having this uh you
know such an unavailability
and you know i'm trying to trying to
stay upbeat about it you know but there
is stoicism here
euler will celebrate her 95th birthday
on sunday
listen i went through the depression i
went through all the wars
i can get through this it is the same
story across this huge state arctic
conditions
have brought texas to a halt this is the
texan town
of euless and just around here 10
000 households woke up with no
electricity
and no heating they were told to keep
the shutters closed to keep the heat in
and as you can see
the roads are very very quiet now the
electricity has returned
sporadically but any optimism has been
tempered by the knowledge
that another snowstorm is forecast to
arrive in the coming hours
texas has wealth and resources but it is
struggling to cope with the crisis
and nobody knows if there's worse to
come adam parsons sky news
tarrant county texas england's
children's commissioner has called on
the government
to put children at the center of the
pm's plan to build back better
once the covert 19 pandemic is under
control
and longfield joins us once again on the
program
and great to have you on on what is of
course you know the beginning of the end
for you is in your time as
as children's commissioner uh not not
something we are celebrating here on the
program you've been
great and always available to come on
and talk to us um i i do wonder though
once again when you're speaking today
at the heart of your approach it's it's
identifying those those disadvantaged
children and
and the problems that they are
experiencing perhaps more than any of us
thanks to covert 19.
yes that's right and um great to be on
um
again um what i've been trying to do
tirelessly over the last six years is
just set out how children experience
life
differently if they have huge
vulnerabilities in their life you know
if they're living in poverty if they're
behind school before they even start
if they've got special educational needs
because the experience of that is
something that
is difficult for people to understand
often that are making the decisions
so there's been an awful lot of children
that have entered the pandemic
not having the resources to draw on that
other children have
it's been a difficult year for everyone
but for those children it's been
particularly tough
so these two parts of the build back
better that i'm asking the pm to put
children at the heart of one is building
back for all children
but the other part is the better for
those kids who weren't
getting their fair share of support in
the first instance for those kids who
were struggling
i think we can do better for them and
that's something will
help them but the country as a whole i i
suppose that if we were to pick a theme
that has run through a thread that has
run through all the conversations that
you of i have had over the
uh the past few months and it has always
been that that
coveted 19 has not created these
problems that you've identified
it has exacerbated problems that predate
the pandemic
yeah that's right it's exacerbated but
it sure it's
it's shown this huge stark spotlight on
the different work the different
experiences that children have growing
up
so of course for families where parents
were able to work at home
with a large house and garden with lots
of resources to draw on
and zoom lessons at the same time that's
one experience
of lockdown but for those kids the
parents couldn't stay at home they
needed to go out to work
they maybe don't have the tech there
they're in cramped accommodation
and there's already things going on in
the household that make it difficult
possibly domestic violence and the like
then it's just a completely contrasting
experience
and of course whilst the pandemic is
awful has been awful for all kids
for those kids it's really amplified
that gap and what we've seen is the
disadvantage group going
and the education gap growing which we
already knew
was quite substantial so the need really
not only to help all children get back
on their feet
but really help boost these children who
are already
behind is enormous we've learnt over the
past
24 hours and that the the algorithm that
the government is using to determine
you know who is most at risk from covert
19 has been altered now includes of
course
ethnicity but also also deprivation
i mean on that topic we are yet to hear
from the government whether or not that
universal credit uplift is
is going to last in in the longer term
what do you make of that given
that we now understand deprivation there
is now an empirical basis on which we
can say deprivation is contributing to
the culvert crisis
well the um uplifting universal credit
has been really important for families
it's placed such a part in families
being able to
get by over these recent months but
they're still in the pandemic they
haven't been able to return to work they
haven't been able to get their
incomes up so now is not the time in my
view
to take away that level of support it's
something which i think
goes to the heart of understanding what
families do need during this period
and also families need for their
children and if we're really committed
to helping children helping families
help their own children flourish
we can't even consider taking away that
uplift at the moment
um it is as i mentioned your last speech
is as children's commissioner i don't
know if it's kind of a last day of term
thing in the office this morning whether
you brought the games in the cakes and
all the rest
i do wonder however if i might tempt you
into just a little bit of candor
about what it has been like when you
have sat down
with ministers what it has been like
when you've sat down with civil service
in whitehall
and you've laid out as you so often have
in this program the problems that our
young people are facing do they
do they do do they understand what is
going on
well the government's a huge institution
full of
a lot of really well-meaning people and
a lot of talented people
and i do seriously believe that most
people come into public life
wanting to do good and would want to see
the best for children
but they get lost they get lost in the
processes and the data
and the fact that government departments
look at the institutions that they
um that are connected with children
rather than the children themselves so
for me really being able to put children
at the forefront and we've seen
president biden doing it with his
huge investment and we've seen it in new
zealand too
is about thinking about how government
needs to reshape itself
so it can understand children's lives
and it can actually
get the policies in place that people
know will make a difference
that's the challenge it's also the
opportunity last question
do you like boris johnson
i think he's very really personal i like
i think one thing that i'm talking about
in the speech
is actually regaining that sense of
confidence
and outward looking um confidence that
we had of a nation during the olympics
that's something that i think we need to
get back to and see
and that's something which i think is
part about getting on the front foot
and enabling all children to play their
part
in the nation's progress at the moment
we're looking at
about a fifth of children who won't be
able to do that and that's a loss
for everyone so i say you know i think
that we need
as a country to have that confidence the
pm
has the opportunity to do it in terms of
children
nicely sidestepped and nicely sidestep
game recognized game
and long field it's always been good to
have you on the show in your role uh and
so all the best for what comes next
thanks for joining us
thank you so much time for us to have a
look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well it
is mild but it is rather unsettled and
that's very much the picture that we're
looking at this week
we've got an area of rain working its
way eastwards across the country today
it's going to hang around
over southernmost counties and then pep
up again this evening it's also going to
be very windy
over western parts of scotland so really
we're starting with a bit of a mish-mash
here's our
rains spreading its way eastward you can
see temperatures already around seven or
eight degrees celsius
uh so frost-free to start the day quite
breezy though and those winds are going
to get to around 60 or 70 miles per hour
over western parts of scotland perhaps
even more than that over the hebrides
best of the weather through these
central areas here we'll see some
sunshine it'll stay mostly dry
temperatures 10 or 11 degrees celsius
that's 52 degrees fahrenheit
showers into northern and western parts
and then that rain
stalling over parts of east anglia and
the southeast it peps up over parts of
wales tonight
makes its way northwards and we start
thursday very much the same way as we
start today
rain in the north and the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways